welcome back to gram unfiltered hosts by
me josh smith and today we are joined by
the divine billy potter
[Music]
i am super excited because i've seen two
episodes of i hate susie and
i'm obsessed you co-created it
you're hustling you're making this
vision happen it's incredible
and to be honest for the first two
episodes i just felt very
very anxious i know
i know it's like a pressure cooker of
anxiety is that something you
really want to create that
comfortability
yeah i'm very much interested in
um anxiety and its effect on us all
globally um and as a
you know quite serious problem and
sort of pulling apart why we are all
living with this feeling um
um and and having that actually
reflected in the work so that it feels
like an immersive experience
not just sort of a sat back oh they look
a bit anxious it's
it's sort of you know purpose built
to make you feel like you are certainly
the first couple of episodes you are
in the body and mind of this woman how
is anxiety played out
in your own life i didn't think i had
anxiety until
seven years ago i didn't i always i
always remembered
myself as um quite a chilled
child and maybe that was true maybe that
is true
my my mum says that um
i was a sort of sunny happy child
um but i think
i don't know i think i'm just coming to
terms with the fact that i
actually have quite acute anxiety
and um maybe i managed that as a kid
or in fact i know i managed that as a
kid um
and also nobody was talking about it so
you didn't really
you couldn't name it and therefore it
had
sort of i don't know it just it can
often go unnoticed
um but yeah i was like an obsessive
cleaner when i was a kid
um in a way that's
beyond um normal
you know what i mean like i mean
actually so being being
not many kids are particularly tidy i
was
i was um like i wouldn't let people sit
on my bed in case they creased it
and quite often i wouldn't let anyone
come round and close
they sort of messed with my room um
and and then yeah i think that
progressed
so it's something i've also seen it
a lot in my family and i continue
to see it so i think it's i think it's
you know i think it's genetic
um combined with the world in which we
live
um so yeah i study it a great deal
yeah and i think for you as well like
you've had to
you've gone through so many different
phases in your career and in your life
in this weird public eye pressure cooker
bubble like
started out as a pop star which
obviously susie does
in the show as well now you look back at
that what was
it almost like that didn't even really
happen to you or like
what's your relationship with that
younger you like now i'm only coming to
terms with that period of my life
i think it's been pretty much um
in the dark like i can't remember a lot
about it
um and i think that's not
good i think um there are
a number of reasons for that um but
mostly
because i worked so hard as a child who
should have been sleeping
and growing and um
but there's also i also experienced
some incredible things and
saw a great deal and um
you know i don't i don't regret that
period of my life but
i'm i'm just
some of those feelings that i had in
that period of time has sort of sat
dormant and they're coming out now
um and yeah i'm sort of coming to terms
with that
um it's certainly not something that i
would ever encourage my children
to do i mean it's kind of disturbing to
think
of myself at that age in
some of those environments what kind of
things did you let go dormant and now
you're like
dealing with well i think the anxiety is
a big one
i think it's a sort of i think i live
for
five years in permanent fight or flight
um the schedules are really demanding
um also i was a teenager full of
hormones so that
anyway is a taxing period of in
in your life you know um
and so it's very aware of my image
in a way that wasn't at all healthy
um and i just worked so many hours i've
never
worked as hard as i did then um
so i think there was this unnatural sort
of adrenal
exhaustion um and
that has i think on some level
has um yeah it's it's
it's it's created something is quite
anxious and sometimes a bit depressive
a lot um but i can definitely
lean into that sometimes but the idea of
self-acceptance is such a difficult
thing
to come to terms with isn't it like the
acceptance of oneself
for you what have been some turning
points in learning to accept
yourself and who you are they've always
been really
like horrible things it's always like
it's the it's the big um
[Music]
stressful moments of suffering within
your life that
force you to look at yourself and change
i mean it's it's it's
um it's a horrible reality but that
that is my reality that is
you know also i think having children
for me
have it's it's made me look at myself a
great deal
and what i don't want to um repeat
or i don't want them to experience even
though i have to accept that i cannot
um completely control their experience
of life even though i'd really like to
the moment of my own experience of life
i'd love to
control that you've kind of had to pivot
so much
like you know you go from being a pop
star to an actress to being your own
creator
have you had to kind of rebel against
this kind of like sexism that still
prevails in our society where it's like
a woman is seen as one thing like you're
a singer now you stay a singer you're an
actress you stay an actress like have
you had to deal with that as well in
order to
speak your truth through your work
yeah yeah i guess i have but i've
i've i haven't let it i haven't let it
stop me
um yeah there's a bit i've noticed a bit
of that but i've been
quite bloody minded about doing what
i've wanted to do
all my life creatively anyway not so
much personally but
um and
so i've maybe seen those knocks as
challenges
um the thing that's kind of
disappointing about
wanting to do a number of things um
except you know and accepting that you
might fail at those things and then
having some successes i think what's
really disappointing
is that people sort of brand you
as like some ambitious [ __ ] and that
that is
somehow bad to be ambitious
as a woman that's the thing i find quite
disappointing but also i don't care you
know whatever
and i guess it also helps you it's very
therapeutic as well isn't it
in that sense because yeah yeah get rid
of a lot of stuff for me
you know this sort of dormant years that
we're talking about i sort of i think i
on some level deal with those dormant
years
that and i'm not even quite able to
articulate
what that is or what that means for me
but um
i know that that plays into all of my
work
and it's so it's a really healthy
experience for me like
yerma which was a really um
you know emotional play
people would ask me if that really
messed with my head but i found it
really um i sort of relished it to be
honest i really needed it
what do you think you've learned about
yourself through playing
this character in i hate susie and also
creating her
that i can be really disassociative
um i sort of can do that
as the character
but also do that as a person and um
and as a sort of protection
um yeah i i
i've noticed that a lot
something else for me to get anxious
about this is something new for me to
examine and take to my therapist
um my like new disassociation
it also just made me think about how
many real highs
you can get and how many lows you can
get in the space of a day
and especially now i mean that's what
i'm that's what lucy and i constantly
talk about
you know it's you have a device in your
hand
all the time that is constantly
determining your moods
because it's like oh i didn't get the
job
oh my kid is hit his head at school
um and it's all coming through all the
time
it's on your person all the time so
you're just constantly dealing with this
like
highs and lows so we we really wanted to
to make um you know oh i've got ibs no
one talks about ibs
maybe ideas can become the new mental
health conversation not to make it sound
like
it was a link obviously like you're
about to be waiting
all the time and obviously that's going
to happen like another thing
or the opposite yeah or just it would
clog you up
yeah i was constipated for four months
of filming that shirt
i was amazing and i'm excited to watch
the rest of the episodes
and just keep creating this content
because we need it
oh thanks so we i will try yeah
well billy i think you're epic and i
love you
though is amazing and i'm excited to
watch the rest of the episodes
and just keep creating this content
because we need it
well make sure you look after yourself
you too and then hopefully see you in
real life soon
bye